oh right badly tilted and I straighten
this out at all oh that's better
oh it might actually be straight for
once that'd be a first for me
ah here we go
alright this got that hello
I know what I forgot Oh as soon as I saw
my hand up there ere we are much better
Oh Brooklyn hair color of the Daleks oh
boy started early ah yeah hey everybody
yeah the Avery I just think of it as the
pride ring given that I usually my
answer to the question of are you gay is
probably not in the way you're asking me
so you know the Tory door from London hi
there cara cara cara I've seen a
pronounced both ways I don't know hi
from Australia
ravenclaw from Sweden hey everybody
hello people I haven't said it -
mistress of all Daleks Oh that'd be a
heck of a title by the way about your
sure professor Oman know your location I
mean I'm not sure if you're in making
note about this shirt or this shirt yeah
Canada I did feel about David the David
and Dan the Game of Thrones how many new
Star Wars trilogy as Bob Iger recently
announced that wasn't a recent
announcement that was announced like a
year ago or at least that it was in
development maybe it got confirmed
recently like I don't know I know a lot
of people have turned on on Game of
Thrones lately and not to say that I'm
loving this season I'm not but I don't
think I'm as prepared to you know string
up the writers as other people are at
least not
not and not as quickly
anyway we got pirates
we got Indiana we got Carolyn boy
everybody's here
Zimbabwe oh dang oh are you a boy or a
girl from the first game so that's like
I knew that the whole thing is that you
know you were making a Pokemon thing but
like no Pokemon well enough uh I didn't
catch it
uh-oh Channel pup is in the house I got
pop-up so I gotta clear off go away
Manchester book Oh God
you folks in the UK yes it's early a.m.
over there so my apologies that you are
even here for this so that's C let's
have a fun evening shall we ah so I'm
trying to bait whether I want to do a
little back and forth on a few things or
whether we jump right to the hair yeah
cuz I know that's like what the well the
name on the live stream is pitching so
we'll see water yes
no I'd like no pretense I'm not drinking
water tonight he's on the booze it's
just cider
it's not like it's vodka uh was it me or
was the new Aladdin clip terrible I
don't know didn't watch it like I
believe that it was but no I don't know
I didn't say it hair hair hey all right
all right all right all right
ah there it is ha ha ha
oh it feels really good to have a
refreshed like I don't even think I can
begin to tell you I how nice it feels to
to have that like it'll come in front of
my face and I'll like catch it in the
corner of my eye like how vibrant the
color is again and
Oh feels so good the color ID I really
do love these colors like at some point
in the future I might try thing cuz like
these are the same colors that I did
before although it's a little bit it's a
little bit heavier on the pink and also
we did kind of a bleed over between the
blue and the pink so it so it actually
goes purple that's some of the crossover
points which we didn't do last time
but like the core colors are the same
that I that I've had before I just
haven't had a refreshed in God 10 months
so like it had faded - all heck Olivia
right I'd like to look into consider
getting some different colors I the main
reason I stuck with these is because
they faded so well um and I don't know
when I'll be able to afford to get this
number because like I don't do this
myself I don't know when I'll be able to
afford to get it done professionally
again so you know ah just uh just
decided to stick with the colors that
faded well I had in mind that pink all
over less your loved it but it didn't
last long I mean like it starts to fade
back for a while but like that this pink
is persistent like when when my
hairdresser went ginge
you know bleached this to read ayat the
part the bit that had been paid before
still had a little bit of pink in I'm
even with even with all the bleach
working at it like this pink is
persistent as heck by the way mr.
Ratburn from Arthur is confirmed gay in
the show by having him married I did see
that I saw that that I saw that news
story and uh which is nice my daughter
watches Arthur sometimes so I I kind of
like that that's like potentially just
like in her radar that she might just
see that that that'll be very cool
what's your favorite Moffett series your
favorite Russell T Davies serie which is
the best out of the two favorite Russell
T Davies is series four favorite Moffat
a series 10
I probably pick series four over series
ten it is close though it is a big gets
Pig yeah
have you seen male gamers American Gods
yet I haven't I mean I read the book
ages ago
I like the Nancy boys better um but no I
seldom seen the show haha oh and there
it is
what are your pronouns whatever you feel
like whatever feels right to say and
everybody take a drink ah thoughts on
Brooklyn nine-nine being renewed for
another season gives me one more year to
try and catch up cuz I'm still behind a
bit on that um I don't know hard time
catching up on things does your shirt
count as part of the drinking game I
don't think so because it's like it's
answering the question that it's asking
so I mean if you want to use it as an
excuse to take an extra drink by all
means go for it I helped launch a book
today after nine months logging times
congratulations
like getting stuff off the ground
especially like stuff that takes as long
as a book because even if you've like
got the spark to like you sit down and
crank out the entire thing it always
takes so much longer than you think it
does because like until you've completed
until you've seen something truly
through the completion I think a lot of
us in our mind we think if I write it
it'll be done except you write it and
then you revise it and then you revise
it again that you have people actually
read it and then you realize crap what I
thought was coming across was it and
then you you bake and go through
revisions based off that then you
finally put it in the hands of an editor
and like it's a log of a process like I
just as someone who's gone through it
it's it's kind of nuts I'm gonna do it
again at some point I'm sure
hahaha you gotta get myself a drink now
drinking tea he's always good I'm like I
only I have coffee to start my morning
but after that I stick with tea I'm a
tea drinker today I wrapped up filming
on my own little spider-man short today
did my best to make it work with
distinctive and original narrative for
the genre just hope it works
fingers crossed for your channel pup I
had been following that you had that you
had that cooking and I I just hope it
comes out to your satisfaction because I
know from experience that the
unfortunate truth of YouTube is the
amount of time you spend working on
something is not automatically gonna be
reflected in the amount of attention
that it gets like some of the stuff I've
spent I spent the most time working on
not a lot of attention not a lot of use
not a lot of sharing but I'm still proud
of them so it makes it worth it okay bye
don't know if you're saying bye but okay
I'm Mary Poppins y'all I didn't really
want to get into it because it's oh
sorry I'm getting in on some on a
internal conversation and that that went
on there so sorry about that cool here
random Game of Thrones question YouTube
crossover question have you seen Jenny
Nicholson's tyrion parody I have not
I've only seen sporadic bits of Jenny
Nicholson I'm not subscribed to her I'm
like I like the little bits that I saw
but just not enough to to follow what
she did
I'm still no I I haven't seen that what
I what I what I got sort of shared with
what was sent to my comment section was
oh god I can't remember the channel now
but somebody did this sketch of the
writers of Game of Thrones dropping the
ball and it's just this back and forth
um uh and you know it's barely costume
is just like a tag one guy you know
george RR martin is the same guy but
like in one shot it's George are on the
other side
writers he's like okay he takes a ball
and it says like it's winter on okay
so this we've been building up to this
for a while so he toss it to them oh
this is very cool
oh we dropped the ball yeah you did you
drop the ball of that and they keep
tossing them balls
it's like Daenerys Tyrians intelligence
and they just keep dropping the balls
it's it's it's funny because it's also
short it's like it's like a minute a
half weeks of the perfect length for
that kind of sketch I always get really
nervous when I like click on something
that's meant to be a comedy sketch and I
see a runtime of more than three minutes
I'm like but but it's tight it's cool
and you need to find that if you haven't
seen it recently did a double feature on
Big Lebowski and Fear and Loathing in
Las Vegas it actually fills fits
decently I guess so because I guess
that's the that's the that's the extreme
mellow and the extreme paranoia ends of
the the drug use spectrum spec spectrum
spectrum to back-to-back those who puns
are the best jokes no puns are the worst
jokes but worst in the best way doors
yes Doris they did pass away and I
actually realized said I don't think
I've ever seen anything the Doris Day is
in I know the name she's a legend but I
think I actually ever saw Doris Day
movie which was a little bit of an odd
thing to realize
ah is there something that went on here
ha give me a second guys feel like I am
being directed on something here that
I'm trying to okay yeah sorry something
go got weird their apologies let me get
back to where I was okay any us a people
in the chat well I mean there's me if
you can't calamity jane is a really
great movie of Doris Day's okay oh oh
man yeah Tim Conway passed away - yeah
yeah it's been a few lately
when Peter Mayhew you know a couple
weeks back boy
sorry guys I don't mean to be going to
silent Jane could you repeat yeah like
somebody tried to draw my attention just
to something earlier and I missed it
yeah like people are telling me to go
check on James comment and I tried to go
back but guys this thing keeps scrolling
so for me to like go back and see
something is is really difficult so if
he could either say it again or if
somebody could quote okay here we go
CEO and social media be so free with
your sexuality and gender inspired me to
come out as bisexual to my mom she took
it well and she honestly wasn't bothered
oh gosh
that yes yes that is oh that is so
wonderful to hear because I'm not like
coming out is one of the most stressful
things that you you have to end up doing
so and and like it so many people I feel
it gets hammered in with most media
representations and most stories that
get told of coming out of people who
didn't accept or at least not right away
or people got thrown out of the house
and all that and it can go well it's
still scary regardless but like it can
go well and that isn't what oh that is
beautiful I was kind of mad but I
laughed when they dropped the ball this
is Tyrians intelligence and the one this
is Jamie's Redemption Ark yeah yeah I
personally as like for my own opinions I
like that that sketch ended on the bran
joke but you know have you seen any
Brooklyn nine-nine episodes that you
disliked not yet I mean like I said I'm
still behind so unless something unless
it's like gone off the cliff in the last
ye season which I haven't heard has been
the case
no I've liked everything I saw
this is really hard I had an easier time
with my mom because I was nervous to
tell my dad because of his beliefs and
how he acts but even he took it well Wow
I love this community thanks so much
guys yeah it was really scary as I have
anxiety but she honestly didn't seem
annoyed even asked me what I want for
dinner afterwards oh this is oh this is
heartwarming dang
it's wild styles air oh oh crap
yes cut is from your perspective when it
comes to entertainment what do you feel
crosses the line from imitation to
ripoff um it's really hard to define
like trying to trying to define the
lines between omage parody imitation
ripoff tribute trying to parse all that
out it's it's like it's like that old
quote I don't know if it was a supreme
court quote but it's like that old legal
quote I can't define obscenity but I
know when I see it it is kind of the
same thing like it's really hard to say
this is the line where it crosses into
being a ripoff versus any of the other
things it could possibly be
it really is a case-by-case basis and
also and I mean part of that's shaded by
personal bias because depending on how
strongly you feel about whatever it is
that is being imitated or ripped off you
might feel more harshly about people who
are copying it whereas other things you
might not care about so much so you know
it's you know tropes exist all over the
place so it is hard to know where where
the lines actually are I don't really
have any LGBTQ stories being a straight
male however my sister has been in a
relationship with a French lady named
Coco they both they both work at Disney
latest chip bugs that
the most adorable thing that I have seen
today oh man
been together almost 10 years well
congrats to them I can't I can't
remember if I shared this story before
so like after I came out to my mother
she didn't like I she didn't see me and
I mean like these days I I do this it's
fairly blended I followed like day to
day I might fall in the middle or waver
whatever but like way back when I first
came out to my mother uh I had a very
firm line I had a wall between male and
female presentation I was all one or all
the other I didn't I didn't mix it up so
she didn't actually see me presenting
feminine for several years after I came
out to her um cuz you know she's never
been to one of my shows and she just
wouldn't have occasion like I offered if
she want to see pictures and initially
she was just kind no and I think it was
just kind of I think I offered that too
quick and then it just kind of fell to
the wayside but what happened was and
this would have been oh this would have
been about almost nine years ago now
when I first moved back to Vermont
so initially because I'm still with my
daughter's mother at that point and we
live with my mother briefly um while we
were working on getting our own place
and I went to I went and I did Vermont
pride that year and I came back you know
still in all this stuff that I was in
these these platform boots and this
short skirt I think I might have even
had fishnets on so I come into the house
with all the stuff on and a wig and full
makeup and like double D breasts forms
and I come into the house and she's
she's just the kid she just kind of
looks at me and pauses and goes you're
really tall and I ah I just love that
that was those that was a wonderful
moment I don't know if anybody in real
life except my significant
other knows I'm Demi internet friends do
though which is nice it is it is always
nice to have some it is always has that
people who know whether it be online in
person
both everybody or you know just just
somebody just just to know it's not you
know something that you're holding on
completely yourself that's that's where
it can get get to be an issue I'm a
straight male I have a lot of bisexual
friends and every day I go to the band
hall just to see two girls who I lost it
seen two girls come play which final
season do you think is the worst Gotham
or Game of Thrones oh well I mean Game
of Thrones isn't done yet
we got an episode left to go um I think
it's it's tough to call potentially it
might end up being Game of Thrones
because I think because of the
overarching story nature of the show I
think a bad ending has the potential to
taint enjoyment of the earlier seasons
because you realize they're not building
to a strong conclusion and I I think
that has the potential to taint the
overall experience more than the season
5 of Gotham because I can go back and
watch earlier seasons of Gotham and just
revel in the madness of it
whereas I think depending on this I mean
I I don't think this is a particularly
strong last episode for Game of Thrones
I don't think one episodes like I don't
think one last episodes gonna save it
but it might determine how far up or
down that ends up ultimately landing
hair is beautiful thank you very much
WTF Gotham yeah like Gotham was so weird
too because like they had an absolute
perfect setup to just go nuts with all
the toys they already had all the
characters they'd already established
they instead brought in Missa al Ghul
and Bane why I don't I will never
understand that decision I know what
that's like when I came out to my mum
she misunderstood what I was telling her
and thought I was at I was saying I was
a crossdresser until I went full time a
year later
well yeah is getting parents understand
it can be a tricky thing and I like
initially I actually was just coming out
to my mother as a crossdresser because I
didn't I hadn't wrapped my head around
gender-fluid at that point
oh the other the other thing was when I
came out to my mother we were still in
New York and I was like like gee sit
down if something I want to talk to you
about and when I told her her her
initial reaction was oh thank goodness I
thought you were gonna tell me that you
two were gonna have a kid and you're not
ready yet I was like well no so that was
a that was interesting they dropped the
no man's playing ball oh oh boy they
dropped that hard yeah Danny the Dalek
Queen who's Nyssa al Ghul exactly that's
my point right there I'm trances
sometimes I don't get it oh yeah like
that and I think like serious note I
think that's something that's helpful
for us to remember that being part of
the lgbtq+ community doesn't give you
like the all axis master key to
understand everything that's going on
there's stuff I still have to do work to
wrap around and like talk about
correctly or respectfully so yeah it's
it's it's a learning process for
everybody offs on the Rosa Marcos
subplot in season two and three of
Brooklyn nine-nine oh god it's been too
long man you can't go that specific on
me on that show it's been too long for
me to remember break this stuff down my
seven-year-old son said he would wear a
dress if it was ink made me smile that
he felt comfortable telling me that Oh
like that's that is they that's that's a
real good sign of a strong
relationship that you have with him that
he is okay telling you that regardless
of whether he ever does it or not the
fact that he knows he can talk to you
about that and just say that and be okay
that's that's a wonderful thing uh a
review of what is behind you Oh God all
this stuff um haha it's oh dude I don't
know it's a lot
I mean it's some of this is stuff I've
gone over in previous videos and most of
the rest of it I talked about I get like
in March because I received a whole
bunch of stuff sent to my PO Box and off
my Amazon wishlist for my birthday so
like it's it's just too much never
thought I could be sexually attracted to
a car but the sixties Batmobile is just
poof I confuse myself over whether I
should say I'm pan or bi but I feel much
more comfortable with the label of buy
it for some reason which is fine and
like that's the funny thing about like
labels labels can really be a
double-edged sword if you find one that
actually does bring you a lot of comfort
and feel stabilizing that's an amazing
thing but like if you can't find one
that feels quite right
the I've seen people like twist
themselves around to try and fit a label
that's close to them but isn't quite
them just to try and feel like they
belong more and like I've seen that go
wrong too so they can really go either
way sometimes the first shelf video was
about 45 minutes if anyone is curious
buy somewhere spank Barclays Chuck's
spanks speak pink sparkly chucks - if
you ever win the lottery which Batmobile
are you getting Batman 89 that's I don't
even have to hesitate on that does
taking drugs to reduce testosterone
reduce your libido so for context I've
talked about I think I mentioned it on
and I've talked about this on the very
wild channel I am a Hans Poorna lactone
which is a testosterone reducer I'm not
on a dose that like brings me down to
like next to zero but I'm on like
basically what's up what amounts to a
half dose versus someone who is
transitioning to full time as a woman so
short answer to your question is yes my
my libido my my sex drive is down
slightly without getting obscene about
it sexual function is not affected but
I'm just I'm a little bit less likely to
initiate anything than I was previously
but it it's it hasn't been it hasn't
like plummeted it hasn't like gone to
nothing so it's been it's been a shift
to that honestly I'm pretty okay with
get that on there I have many little
Batmobiles can't relate as I don't have
a car there's some interesting
conversations going on in here can you
start doing rankings as premier so we
can guess what your picks will be
rankings of what I'm not sure I'm
totally getting the question there
[Music]
gentle pop I'm not even gonna repeat
that question because that's just too
ridiculous
um have you ever seen supernatural no I
am NOT fights my gender in a Starbucks
carpark oh is that why it is that way
there was the company in Game of Thrones
do you like you left it there you want
to go battle your gender just got out of
the shower so I'll only be on a little
cuz I have to go to bed in five to ten
minutes all right I see you Totoro dang
right you do
there we go I am most purely attracted
to females sexually and almost purely to
men romantically is that just the same
as bisexual um bisexual would be the
easy like punchy way to to say it so
like I've said that that's like bisexual
with an asterisk
there's probably terminology that is
more specific to your situation that
might apply but like I don't think
bisexual I don't think you're miss
labeling yourself if you were to call
yourself bisexual wait so for someone
who doesn't know things how does
reducing testosterone change how you
feel mentally physical whatever since
it's not like you're also taking
yesterday okay so hang on so here was
sort of the operating theory that my
primary care physician and I were
operating on when we decided to try
putting me on testosterone blockers
which is that like I I am gender fluid
so my sense of self meanders one way or
the other but the thing is is that
because I was born male and like
biologically that's where things are
that means that when I you know however
I'm feeling my default setting
like if males over here and females over
here my default was always heavily this
way just because of my own physical
makeup so the idea of reducing my
testosterone was basically to sort of
bring my sort of my neutral to being
something closer to the middle so that
like day to day a I'm not automatically
already leaning masculine because that
means if I want to go feminine work to
get this over the other way but if it's
closer to the middle it becomes almost
an equal amount of work for me to go
feminine or to go masculine or to just
leave it more in the middle um so
that was sort of the idea of reducing
the testosterone without upping estrogen
and and and it's worked out well for me
the the side effects have been what like
the most severe potential side effect
was sterility I got a vasectomy anyway
so but that wasn't something I was
worried about and other side effects
have been non-existent to manageable so
you know we're about to be executed
educator when he takes a swing before
talking I want to eat them muffin Oh
friggin muffin man Oh so do people
actually like Hershey's and other
American chocolates or is it all just an
aisle um the thing is like Hershey's is
practically a monopoly in a lot of ways
like you have to go out of your way to
get chocolate that isn't Hershey's or
isn't that style or isn't trying to be
like Hershey's it's not not like it's
impossible to find but like Hershey's is
easy to get and cheap so it's what most
people have ready access to regardless
of whether it's what they prefer or not
a whole station about muffins down here
oh I know Andrew I know it is wonderful
here is it yes yes it is Hershey's is
nasty Hershey's is great like and all
like worth acknowledging some people do
genuinely like it as well like I'm I'm
kind of indifferent um like milk
chocolate is I think it's not my least
favorite kind of chocolate but I called
my least favorite kind of typical
chocolate cuz in my mind it's it's milk
white and dark and out of those like
milk is my least milk chocolates my
least favorite and that's Hershey's
entire thing for the most part I admit
that cab Berry's much richer and just UK
chocolate in general feels like a tier
above American
yeah yeah but that's that's valid
favorite Ben and Jerry's favorite
current Ben & Jerry's is huge it depends
on my mood it's either gonna be coffee
coffee buzz buzz buzz or triple caramel
chunk it was Vermont II Python but they
discontinued that flavor which annoyed
me my favorite kind of chocolate milk
chocolate white chocolate dark and mint
chocolate that's like all the chocolates
dude dude in the non-gendered forum
because anybody can be dude oh you know
what there was there was something I
missed back here let me get I mean back
up for a second ah stranger things is
getting the Lego treatment okay um I
would like to see the Lego dem accorded
like I want to see what that looks like
polarizing question time sleep with
socks on or off and do you like mint in
chocolate mint and chocolate is terrific
socks on in cold weather otherwise no
thanks for your candor about your life
experiences hey like I'm look can I be
I'm front part of it is the fact that
I'm egotistical and I actually enjoy
talking about myself but you know even
saying that and being a little bit
flippant about it part of it also just
was knowing that people or at least the
the people who had been actively
supporting me and who care about me
don't flee from this step for me from
Who I am so you know I I can joke about
how you know I'm egotistical and just
like to talk to myself and there's some
truth to that but I even taking that
into account you know I didn't I didn't
come out on this channel till last year
you know I'm in my eighth year of doing
this so there there obviously was still
stuff that I was afraid of for a while
it feels good to not be afraid it really
really does kinder eggs are leash hurt
legal now I know you've seen endgame but
I thought I'd ask if you'd seen it yes I
saw endgame enjoyed it quite a bit too
um also salted caramel is my favorite
I do like salted caramel I feel like
that got over put like not quite - um
pumpkin spice levels but I do feel like
salty caramel started turning up in too
many things will you be watching the new
doom movie well uh well yeah Denis
Villeneuve he makes good interesting
movies yeah I'll watch that I'm starting
a new channel soon got any advice tell
me anything good and now subscribe
automatic advice note I really don't I
think the only advice I can give you is
just be sure that whatever you do that
you will enjoy doing it even if nobody
watches because statistically speaking
that's probably gonna be what happens so
you know it's it's this it's the same
advice that I give anybody going into
any creative endeavor whether it be
writing filmmaking or YouTube and let
unless you've got some sort of true leg
up or in or something that you know okay
if I do this it will lead to something
or at least is very likely to if you
don't have that kind of leg up on what's
going on then just be sure you you like
what you're doing now tell us expensive
I never like no tell us fine I never I
never got into the whole nutella
addiction
did you hear rumors that there will be a
musical episode in series 12 no no I
didn't hear that
ah and I don't know how I feel about
that what were viewers you watch online
I know you've mentioned Jeremy Johnson
your channel before but do you watch him
or any others I I do what Jeremy Jones
um
I watch Bob Shipman whose movie Bob his
review he keeps he was moving channels
in terms of where his actual reviews go
up um so I got eggs back on The Escapist
now there aren't all that many just
straight up reviewers I mean Stu bagful
kinda is um at least in in terms of
Doctor Who specifically um yeah I used
to watch Chris Stockman years ago I
can't kind of fell off that not like
he's suddenly um like got bad or
anything I'm just thinking like yeah I
don't need to keep following this so
yeah like actually not all that many
like III enjoy the more in-depth stuff
like the like the video sa kind of
things like like Lyndsey Ellis does do
you paint no I in terms of the the
visual arts like drawing painting like
no I I'm not good my seven-year-old is
already a better artist than I am
talking about that kind of stuff
movie Bob's on escapist again yeah
husband for a few months now and yet
actually just finished again I guess he
finished out his contract on geek.com so
he's on he's not on that channel anymore
now he's just now he's just doing his
reviews on The Escapist
and he still got his own channel worries
where he's doing the and Bob We Trust
and he's been working on the Star Wars
really that good like forever but now
that'll come out one of these days I
really like fail will 34 his reactions
are amazing not familiar with that one
have you ever watched saber sparks
videos I feel like I've seen something
from saber spark because I know that
name thrillers productions that one I
don't
yeah oh yes so the new Picard series is
going up on Amazon I did see that that I
got picked up it was actually it was
funny I hadn't realized that it didn't
actually have a network yet and then
that I saw the news I'm like oh okay
[Music]
did did you see the series Dexter yes
yes I saw Dexter my my feelings about
the finale at least are well documented
searchable on this channel Oh drink the
pain away um what else was the oh there
were some there were some trailers that
came out today that I was like I'm
finally remembering I did have stuff I
was gonna talk about um there was a
trailer well there was the trailer for
the Maleficent sequel and I don't know
what they're playing at with this and
because it feels like they're trying to
evoke the the evil wickedness of
Maleficent again but the entire first
movie was about ultimately was about how
she's actually the hero of the story and
I'm so I'm like what are you doing cuz
like I grant you evil Maleficent is more
fun but like you you made your bed you
need to lie in it what what is this do
you think the new Picard series will be
any good given it's done by the same guy
as Star Trek discovery I have no idea
because I haven't seen Star Trek
discovery so I can't I can't use that as
a metric either way Michelle Pfeiffer's
the real villain calling it out one yeah
Michelle Pfeiffer I mean she's really
good as a villain and like I that as
well but even if even if they're not
turning maleficent back into a villain
they're still very much they want her to
still come across as evil and wicked and
scary even though she wasn't that by the
end of the first movie so like they're
really trying to have their cake and eat
it too
I was surprised Maleficent got a sequel
I didn't think anyone but me actually
liked it I wanted to like it I like the
I like the first act I liked the first
20 minutes or so um but it kind of falls
apart for me after that have you seen
the magician's I have not if heard a lot
of good things about it but no I have I
haven't gotten to that one do you think
that if done well see Devils could be
very creepy and modern who actually like
modern who has only really done anything
even close to an underwater setting I
think once and that was Cold War good so
honestly yeah I think if they did if
they did a story like set in a trench
and like play the mystery and do not
don't spoil the sea Devils in the
marketing or the next time on Doctor Who
or any an act if they can keep a lid on
it and give us like that that creepy you
know the the dark and the crushing
depths of the ocean and what the heck is
down here kind of thing and then
introduce the sea Devils through that
and yeah heck they really want to go
nuts take another crack at the Merc up
through that I think it could be really
good potentially that's always the thing
no idea is guaranteed to work and I
always have to specify that because
series 11 of doctor who actually did a
lot of stuff that I said the show should
do but the execution still didn't
actually have all of it work as well as
I would have liked so I always feel the
need to to add that
oh yeah the 12th doctor on with the
ghost yes yeah that's right so um was
after the after the flood under the lake
and after the flood although like I kept
forgetting that that one was set under
water cuz I'd like I felt like the focus
was more on the ghosts and since it was
only a lake it couldn't have that
same like you know the crushing black
depths of the ocean so well that one
technically was underwater and it's not
it didn't quite have the vibe I'm
talking about
Maleficent frustrated me because it was
just Disney making their version of
wicked and if you wanted to make a story
like wicked just make wicked well Disney
didn't have the rights to wicked I know
does it was Universal last I knew
whoever wasn't been sitting on it
forever
almost all ideas can be good it's just
how they're executed that determines
their quality that is incredibly true
like any idea can be done well any idea
can be done badly now that said I do
think there are so good ideas and bad
ideas insofar as some ideas are easier
to make something good out of and some
ideas are much harder to make something
good out of so like on that scale I
would still say some core ideas can be
better or worse but even a terrible core
idea can result in a good product I mean
that's basically the entire filmmaking
career of Lord Miller like they just
keep taking stuff this like that's a
terrible idea and they make something
really good out of it I honestly don't
know how they do that wicked is still
owned by Universal the movie should be
out next Christmas I'm pretty sure
that's been the case over the last few
years running are you going to review
Shazam
um review I don't know I mean I'll see
it eventually once it's once I can get
it on streaming oh speaking of streaming
um Disney just bought comcast out of
there
their third ownership of Hulu so Disney
and now basically owns Hulu which
initially made me think oh are they just
gonna fold all that into Disney Plus but
I don't think they are because that this
is gonna give them access to and also a
place to put all of the more adult
properties that they acquire through
like say the Fox Steel because they got
they got their hands on like a ton of
stuff that they probably don't want to
put the
Disney brand name on like alien like
often top my head so I I have a feeling
Hulu is going to become for streaming a
bit like what one of us to pictures is
or was at some point for Disney films
which is the the banner under which
stuff that is not necessarily true to
the Disney branding that is still being
released by the same company so I figure
that's how that goes and he thoughts on
the upcoming Watchmen series I don't
know what to make of that trailer I I
really really don't can they put song of
the south on there I mentioned this in a
live stream like a little bit of back a
little bit ago they have said they won't
release that I don't know why they're
hiding from this movie at this point
it's not like we don't know what it is
we all know what it is it's actually
it's drawing more attention to it but
the fact that they won't just release it
like with you know uh just an intro at
the front end saying hey contexts we
wouldn't make it this now but it's a
thing we did I don't know do you think
doctor who could make it with really out
there story arcs like having the doctor
turn evil for a few episodes um I I
don't know about having the doctor turn
evil I think what you could do is you
could do almost like a doctor light
episode from the perspective of someone
not on the TARDIS like so like on a
planet where the doctor lands and stuff
is going on and what you could do is you
could have the story from this person's
for strange so it becomes a bit like say
Sally Sparrow in in blink and there's
you know this thing going on that you
that you know is screwing everything up
and that they're scared of and you'd
think it's a monster that the doctors
alternately gonna come and save them
from you find out it's the doctor not
because he's being evil but because
there's collateral damage to the stuff
that he or she does
I keep defaulting to saying here I'm
trying to train myself to do they so
oh I I think something like that could
be a way to portray the doctor in a
different light without having to
actually have them turn evil for a
little bit which I I'm not gonna say
that's impossible to do well but I think
it's honestly it's just kind of cheesy
would you be for having rose or Captain
Jack come back
Captain Jack yes roads no although I
would like Billy Piper to come back as
the as the moment guys the the bad wolf
entity in some form I don't know how I
don't know why I would like that do you
think it would boost the story of the
ninth doctor was in Utopia um not really
I don't think that would have had a huge
at least not as I'm picturing in my head
I don't think that would have had a huge
impact either way do you think the
epicness of Avengers endgame kind of put
a halt on any other MCU potential
blockbuster to come out um yes and no
here's my expectation on that because
they've announced additional Marvel
projects of course but they have not
announced any more Avengers films so for
my money they will stop having the big
crossover event films at least for a
little while because it kind of can't go
bigger than an game went so they're
gonna put the big crossover event films
to bed and like they'll probably just
have more characters crossing over in
smaller capacities in the normal films
kind of like how Doctor Strange just
turned up and Thor Ragnarok well at
least you have that Disney attraction
from Song of the South yeah that's the
other thing that's weird about the Song
of the South thing cuz they've got
Thunder Mountain and they still use
zippity-doo-dah
and like just yeah I did they're weird
about it I'd like to see ten and
thirteen complimenting each other in a
story and make you fun know each other's
long coats
I would now that I have a Tenth Doctor
coat I would like thirteen to point out
you don't even have a slit down the back
so the
the wind blows he just the whole thing
takes off like it's it's we it's like
the only long code I have that doesn't
have any kind of slit down the back for
a split it's just completely level it's
weird I've never had a coat like that
before
gonna head out piece and stay away of
stay aware of flying muffins oh we are
we are always aware is the player of
games review still coming out in June
the other day my dad was like the guy
you gave this money to is he actually
doing anything oh geez um well I don't
want to don't want to let down you or
your dad yes June is still the plan for
that review it is on it's it's moving
forward I'm working on it
yeah I die that will that that will come
out in June so you can you're gonna you
can tell your dad that this total
stranger who took your money said oh
yeah it's coming I'm sure he'll be
totally reassured by that any news on
the bisexual rep video yes the person
who I'm going to have on has started
doing research and taking notes because
that's just kind of the kind of person
they are so knowing that they're doing
that hopefully he'll get shot soon that
it may not end up being the June video I
may bump up my video on the barrier
queers trope and do that for June but by
July I should have that one it's it's a
process
someone once joked about how you could
have multi doctor stories with series
ain't Capaldi's here he's not your buddy
series Dan Capaldi because they're all
so different I
they are but I see I love that cuz I do
feel there is a trajectory and an arc I
none of it feels like this isn't the
same guy like I feel like one logically
leads from the other I know not everyone
does but I do
do you watch any other English Joe and
telly other than Doctor Who um I don't
think there's anything else that's like
current that I'm watching for British TV
like I've watched tons of British TV
over the years I don't think there's any
other currently running shows that I
watched though my mother is completely
engrossed in Midsomer Murders so that's
that's become our new or new binge
what is your shirt ah what does my shirt
say my shirt says are you a boy or a
girl sometimes I wanted to see 11 and 13
they're both so bouncy so are you going
to do a video about the whole Game of
Thrones series um probably not um like I
I'm debating like I feel like everybody
in there and their brothers gonna do
this but I'm debating doing a video
talking about why season 8 has gone down
the way it has but I feel like a ton of
people are gonna be doing this or might
not have a much of a contribution there
what I'm definitely gonna be doing is
Liz and I will be doing a top 10
characters from Game of Thrones once it
ends like we did for Buffy and actually
later this week we did for Gotham so
that'll be out on Friday so we'll we'll
be doing that for Game of Thrones -
that's probably about as close as
outcome though because like to do like a
proper overview review I'd have to go
back and re-watch a whole bunch of it
which it's not like I'm opposed to I'd
be happy to but don't time uh you know
day job as long as I am holding down a
day job and and this is not paying my
bills
I just don't have the time to do some of
these bigger projects and then the ones
that I'm tackling like they take a while
to get to a t-shirt idea people think
gender is a simple male or female but
it's more like a big ball of
wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey stuff
nicely done Ben and to whoever is
talking wheel of time I have such high
hopes for the series I forgot that got
optioned Gotham is underrated on series
four with the peak murder Oh professor
peg was great I really loved that that
little mini Arkin
in season four favorite episode of Red
Dwarf um it's probably marooned I think
so so we need to give this to be your
day job um not to over plug myself but
ideally yeah like there's there's a lot
more than I could get done if the if the
patreon ever grows to the degree where
it's enough to pay my bills because
they'd like to get an idea of just sort
of format um and like in would just be a
baseline if you go back and look month
or two ago at like my Titans review that
took me a long time to do but sort of
that level of presentation of
integrating the footage more of having
it more of a structured thing where I
where I'm really breaking it through in
order to make an overall point about
something I would like to do more things
like that but the reason is it's hard
for me to do this because they are such
a time-sink and like I can
you probably all only crank out
something of that style maybe if I'm
lucky once a month and even that is
pushing it depending on what it is I'm
working on so like this month I'm
working on a I'm working on a thing with
with Cowboy Bebop that is taking me
forever
I'm gonna be really happy with the
results I'm I'm pretty sure and it's the
kind of thing I would like to do more of
cuz it's like I'm gonna be an overview
of the whole series but it's really hard
to find the time you know while also
holding down a nine-to-five that's
that's just kind of what it is I did
send you an email pertaining to
suggestions for patreon yes Cass I got
that and actually some of those
suggestions were pretty helpful and some
of them are liable to get integrated so
you might actually see some of those
some of those things come in and that I
appreciate that
like I appreciate the support I get on
patreon I support I appreciate you know
the people dropping in the tip jar on
the live streams i apprec appreciate
people just watching I appreciate all of
it always and knowing that people want
to see me get better and to succeed at
doing this that's that's that's
heartwarming stuff and maybe at some
point we'll get there Oh keep plugging
away at it I love it too much to stop
regardless and you know some days it
really does feel like a pipe dream the
idea that that this you know between you
know revenue off of the videos
themselves and patreon that this could
actually be my living and other times
it's like
get there huh but you know who knows and
I think the other thing is like if I had
if I had if I had full days to put into
this um not only do I think I could get
more done video wise I think I actually
have time to get other stuff done so
like I've got I've got three novels in
various stages of completion I've got
one that's basically done and needs
fine-tuning I've got one that's almost
done and I've got one that I'm about a
third of the way into but you know
trying to get these to a state of polish
is again it's it's just it's more time
and it's it's the one thing that I I
can't make more of you're really good at
it we love watching you thank you
Maureen why are you so surprised because
despite my despite my ego which I do
have a sizable one I'm I never stopped
being surprised at people connecting
with anything that I do that's always
what I hope for but there's always the
nagging voice in the back of your head
that says nobody cares but like I have
enough of an ego that I push through
that and say I don't care I'm doing it
anyways but there's still part of me
that that thinks nobody will ever see
this and if they do they won't care so
anything that gives me the concrete
evidence that that is not the case is
always gonna kind of surprise me in a
great way
I like finishes new plan way more than
the original and creating a new universe
with no suffering I mean like people
picked apart his original plan so I do
think it was actually interesting an
endgame that he he revised and updated
his plan want to ego battle with me I
think you'll find a suitable challenge
indeed I don't know where I was going
with that
Oh book what about Oh God
okay so I have a I have a fantasy world
one base again basically completed book
like it needs I've had a couple of
people read it I need more beta readers
I need an editor or I'd like this
there's the whole process to go through
on that but I've also got another book
set in that same world that is basically
done I've got a third book kind of
outlined and then the one that I've
started working on that I'm about a
third of the way into is actually a it's
it's a polyamory romance book which is
bit outside my wheelhouse writing wise
but I'm enjoying I am enjoying working
on are the new colors significant yes
they fade well so I can get away without
having to pay to get this refreshed for
a while that reminds me we're not done
with that yes I know I know am i late um
a little we're gonna be wrapping up soon
which one do you like more Dark Crystal
abla labyrinth labyrinth I mean I liked
art crystal don't get me wrong the
labyrinth every day twice on Sundays
I'm not a fan of prequel series that
disregard its source material and then
go no no it's fine we'll fix it later
and I don't trust these writers to pull
something together as well Oh I'm
assuming we're talking about the
potential Game of Thrones prequels well
the first thing to realize it's not
going to be the same people who are
doing the series proper they've got
completely new people pitching these
these Game of Thrones prequel series so
if you're worried about the people
involved its new people so be aware of
that
hey we always get those doubts in our
heads as creators oh yeah I always think
my writing will never matter and same
for my artist friends who get nothing
but like three reblogs and tweets online
yeah like that you'll you'll go for a
while of stuff like being middling in
terms of reaction response you know
little 2 to nothing and if you're lucky
every now and then something will sort
of take off and do better than you
expect or get a more heartfelt reaction
than you expect and that's sometimes
that stuff keeps going seriously your
your amazing love your work you are a
true inspiration Thank You Trevor I
appreciate that
medieval oh you mean like for the
fantasy novels I'm a bit a bit sort of
steampunky in terms of setting yes I
Lord of the Rings prequel to are you
publishing under a pen name well I mean
like fiction I well no fiction I have I
wrote I wrote a play under Vere a while
that's available on Amazon um you need
to be 18 if you're gonna buy that play
but the the the fantasy novels like the
Mike my fiction in
terms of short stories what I've
submitted short stories around the book
I've shopped around nobody's bitten like
if I ever published that that'll
probably go under by my legal name which
is Nathaniel Wayne but I you know it
published basically an autobiography and
and a play under virile wild you said
you didn't finish a few notes on the
culture because it felt like homework
I'm curious
without that did you get that bang
cement the culture to be a utopia yeah
like I think I've picked up most of what
I've needed from context which is how I
prefer to get it so I've been okay
Doctor Who prequel anyone know know uh
we can we call it classic whoo there you
go I like you answer to almost all my
questions things well you're welcome
it's funny like I I don't mean to I feel
like I tend to answer questions from the
same people a lot I don't
I actually don't mean to play favorites
and I hope it never comes across like I
do but like for some reason my eyes just
zero in on on some things and like it
creates a pattern the frozen plains and
The Magician's apprentice could have
been so much more that's possible
Nathaniel one-hand Bruce Wayne's left
lesser-known brother well actually if
you know your your DC Batman lore
Nathaniel Wayne was in fact Bruce
Wayne's ancestor from closer to colonial
times look at the big nerd brain on me
nothing um fans know Hollywood yes this
means yes more prequels yeah pretty much
do you have a guilty pleasure form of
entertainment minor trashy romance
novels a la Harlequin i legit bought a
Kindle so people wouldn't see me reading
them
um yes but I'm also gonna asterisk that
because generally I don't describe much
of anything as a guilty pleasure because
I don't believe in feeling guilt about
the things that you enjoy so long is
what you enjoy doesn't cause harm to
anyone else if you like it you should
not feel guilty so and also yeah because
I don't go in for the so bad it's good
there's a lot of things that for other
people are guilty pleasures like but
there are things that I enjoy that I'm
like I get why like people don't dig
this so there there are things like that
Gotham honestly is that a little bit for
me I love it to death but it's it's
glorious trash um or things like repo
the Genetic Opera again I love it but
it's it's insane
if I were to single something out though
I suppose I have ha ha I have a soft
spot for naughty comics so like senior
year high school I started reading heavy
metal and like one of my favorite comic
book artists and writers is Richard
Moore who's best known for boneyard
which is kind of pg-13 ish but he also
does owe a fair amount of very I'd porn
to comics and fantastic artists and I
enjoy that stuff and that's not
something that I I tend to talk about
too much because I don't know yeah I
think he get weird looks like like
talking about that sorry I guess if I if
if there was gonna be anything like that
I might label a bit of a guilty pleasure
I think I do like those kinds of comics
are not on the Shelf with most of my
others in the more public areas of the
house they are
they're away where the nuts is gonna get
glanced at so yeah I suppose there's
there's a little guilt as there's a
little blush on the cheeks on those
heavy metal like the movie yes that
heavy metal this is a proudly weird
community amen
I think Big Finish have milked the Time
Lord they have it I'm actually curious
to check that out cuz I I don't think
the show should ever do the time more
like ever but Big Finish
one of the things I really like about
Big Finish is because they don't have to
visualize stuff they can actually do
much more abstract ideas and until I
actually think the time war potentially
a better fit there as a heavy metal fan
did you watch Metal Hurlant chronicles
the TV show no not familiar with that my
guilty pleasure was you Jia ho like you
see I still love it and I'm not ashamed
anymore
yay
in case you didn't catch my last comment
the Doctor Who prequel thing was a joke
please don't destroy me today I shall be
kind
well that's it for my cider that might
be the cue to look into wrapping it up
for the night I don't know if I feel
guilty about it but I love ya
I like given what I labeled as my guilty
pleasure I I'm not gonna blame you if
you do feel a little guilty about it but
ya know no shame in that if you don't
want to feel it guilty pleasures are
weirdly wholesome thing Pollyanna guilty
pleasure is a stream fire movie there is
no guilt in the street fighter movie
that is glorious what do we say to the
goddess of nurdrage not today uh mine
was drawn together Oh
drawn together that's that's a solid
candidate for uh for guilty pleasure I
think I did they did about a season and
a half that I'd just kind of fade it on
it but yeah I didn't see enough of it
hmm yeah solid you drinking know things
weird things but you know things I might
steal that my guilty pleasure is the
doom movie underrated like honestly it's
not great but like it deserves more
respect than kiss hmm I think mine is
sky-high oh I feel bad now cuz I ripped
into that movie a couple months ago
oops uh guilty pleasure reigning supreme
total drama and the Supergirl movie all
right I did the I did two seasons of
Total Drama I did total drama island
which I loved and then it was I think
Total Drama Camp something like that
I'd like I know it kept going after that
I'm like oh god they're gonna keep
milking this and I backed off but like
those first couple seasons I loved
those were awesome
King Kong 2005 is the best movie ever
made do not debate me on this
yeah go ahead have it Avira knows much
tell some knows things others do not
oh I like that - guilty pleasure mine
might have been The Watchmen movie oh I
have so much anger at the Watchmen movie
oh I remember coming out of that movie
and I saw with with my daughter's mother
and she was like I don't think it was
very good and I tried to explain no but
it's this is that and I realized I'm
explaining why the comic was good and
I'm not defending this movie I'm making
excuses for it and then I looked at it
with the more critical eye and one no I
hate this I know I have friends who love
the Watchmen movie and I'm still friends
with them so like it it's valid oh I
hate it hate it so much uh have you read
the name of the wind I have not my
guilty pleasure is light novels which
are the trashy anime know which are like
the trashy anime are adapted from haha
I had the ultimate cut of Watchmen on
blu-ray I enjoy it a lot I'm glad I'm
glad you do so you like bad boys I was
so bad at being a boy I became a girl uh
do you watch YouTube in your free time
what do you watch uh yeah sometimes um
try think you know I I mentioned some of
them are the few reviewers I watch movie
Bob Jeremy Jones I like Yahtzee
cronshaw's stuff
- bag full a spree
crispy Pro nests drunk I enjoy like John
Oliver you know he upload huge chunks of
last week tonight go up on YouTube I'll
watch those there there's other stuff
but I'm just I'm just drawing Lindsey
Ellis folding ideas innuendo studios so
yeah like I'll fall I'll fall down a
YouTube rabbit hole sometimes I really
should wrap it up though cuz I oh god
it's past 10 o'clock my time I need to I
need to shoot a video I got to edit
another one and I gotta get my fabulous
looking butt into bed so do you think
sue bankfull is the doctor who review
equivalent of Yahtzee I'm not sure but
it's not an unfair comparison so
remember we care I care about you to all
of you I hope that you have a wonderful
night or morning depending on where
you're located wonderful week wonderful
month however long things can be
wonderful I hope that for all of you you
are beautiful
you're valid you're loved and I'll see
you alive again in a week